hey guys in this video I'm gonna give
you 12 tips on how to be a gentleman why
well because these days there's a lot of
guys out there who don't know how to be
a real gentleman and being a gentleman
will bring that spark you want in a
relationship now you already have that
spark that spark will turn into a flame
that will keep you going for the long
run let's get to the video right now
just very quick if it's your first time
here welcome to my channel and then if
you haven't subscribed yet please do and
then click that notification balance you
won't miss any of the next videos now
you need to know that you are not born a
gentleman it is something that you can
learn so becoming a gentleman is a
choice and anyone can learn so with that
said let's start with the first step
be punctual on time there's no excuse
for being late my grandfather always
said go early enough to fix a flat tire
meaning go early enough make sure you
have enough time so that if something
does go wrong then you'll have enough
time to fix it and still be on time now
if you're a guy who's always late it
shows her that he don't respect her
enough you don't respect her time beyond
time and she will feel important to you
say please and thank you it's so easy
and yet so many people don't do it if
you don't have these basic manners it
gives off a very strong negative message
about you you got to show her that you
appreciated when she when she does
certain things for you if you don't it
clearly shows her that you're taking her
for granted only if you say please
you're right where are my manners
please please that's all you had to say
oh thank you so remember please and
thank you
next one is to stand up which enters the
room if you do that it shows her an
enormous amount of respect towards her
and she'll feel special and valued and
then of course you do the exact same
thing when she exits the room
help her to be seated if you want to be
a gentleman all you gotta do is to make
her feel like a lady it's not difficult
all you gotta do is just pull out the
chair for her and then as he goes to sit
when her knees bent then you gently push
the chair forward and then if you're at
the place where there's no more chairs
available and you see it then stand up
get on her one
or better yet give her yours help her
with her coat when she just got into the
building she's too hot then just ask her
sorry but could I help you with your
coat and then she would normally agree
and then you just go behind her and
gently help her to slip out of it and
then you do the same thing to help her
put it back on again when she wants to
leave table manners look you gotta have
the basic table manners it's it's not
the same for all cultures for example I
think to China and there they don't mind
chewing with their mouths open and verb
openly in front of each other it's no
big deal
but in most other countries it is now
you can go and learn a lot about table
manners but it's important to know the
basics here's a few never talk or chew
of your mouth full of food
never slurp drinks wait until everyone
has food before you eat make sure your
face and hands are clean before you come
to the table another reach to get
something instead ask someone to pass it
and then also wait for everyone to
finish their meals first before you
stand up and if you want to leave the
table ask if you may be excused and
lastly when you leave push your chair
back in
a gentleman keeps his word never ever
make a promise that you cannot keep if
you make a promise to somebody do it
keep it I promise
whatever happens you'll never be alone
again
[Music]
going to hold you to that James Fraser
you have my word Klaas laser you only
have to break a promise once to damage
your reputation and lose someone's trust
your yes should always mean yes and your
no should always mean no open the door
what door every door for example open
the car door and close it gently when
she's in and you do the same thing to
help her out of the car you just open
the car door for me yes for there no
one's ever done that before do it again
and the same goes for the door of the
restaurant or any other building and
then very important let her enter first
give her many and also sincere
compliments if you see her for the first
time the words out of your mouth is very
very important what you say in that
moment so if you see her and you think
man she looked amazing and say
amazing don't just make things up sir
because you want her to think that I
give you a nice new give compliments no
be sincere if you think about something
that you like about her then tell her
be polite not just to her but to
everyone and that includes waiters at a
restaurant never just see a person as a
label treat them the way you want them
to treat you remember there's a story
behind every single person and the way
you treat people says a lot about your
character our gentleman is always polite
to everyone and not just with what he
says but how he says it next one is to
carry her heavy baggage and I'm not
talking about emotional baggage here I'm
talking about real literally her baggage
heavy trash bag shopping bags suitcases
whatever the gentleman will always ask
her if he can help her to carry the
baggage which way to the elevator
elevator no no
[Music]
listen and never interrupt a gentleman
will always listen to what a lady wants
to say and he will never interrupt her
especially if she's talking about deep
and serious things if you really listen
she will know you care
and if you don't interrupt her she will
know that you're giving her the space to
open up and that shows you have
self-control now remember this guy's
there's a lot of things in the world
that will go out of style
but a true gentleman will never ever go
out of style
now if you have some time sticker on
watching more of my videos and I'll see
you there cheers guys